is
is
[Music]
foreign
is
is
is
positive
uh
foreign
is
is
is
foreign
is
unfortunately
[Music]
is
specialist
different
what
the world will not accept such a return
to the past thank you very much sir
i think the vice president and minister
for foreign affairs of the republic of
colombia
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of paraguay
senora presidente senor
secretary general president
senora secretary general visa president
the colombia vice president of colombia
for reasons
is
mutually acceptable
situations
this is why today we have decided to
sponsor and vote for the draft
resolution which was submitted to the
consideration
of the general assembly
as we did last friday
with the profession presented to the
security
security council must play its role and
exercise its functions
we hope that the series of mechanisms it
has
and which we heard
in the statements of its members
yesterday can be urgently activated
and begin to produce results to
re-establish
peace and security
above all
and most urgently
relieve the pain and suffering of all
those affected in this regard we
highlight the meeting held yesterday at
the request of the delegations of france
and mexico to assess the humanitarian
situation in the field
and determine the
name
we also
join the call for all parties to
facilitate the arrival of humanitarian
assistance
and humanitarian personnel and to
urgently
respond to the needs of all those in
vulnerable situations particularly women
and children
mr president distinguished colleagues
fundamental rights
of all those affected by the conflict in
ukraine
as appropriately pointed out by the
foreign minister at the higher level uh
segment of the council
and i quote
violations have become
undesirable
[Music]
point of human rights where the right to
life
is the most precious right that needs to
be protected
there's also an imperative need to
quickly return to the negotiation
process in a constructive flexible
fashion
on the basis of
current international mechanisms and
strict adherence to international law
the principles of the charter of the
united nations
independence
we have been making since the very first
day in our statements this is the only
the talks which began yesterday morning
will be the beginning of emerging from
this crisis in a sustainable lasting
fashion reiterating the need to reach an
immediate ceasefire
in order for these talks to continue
without
any preconditions thank you very much mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
of paraguay
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
dominican republic
to deal with the situation created by
the military occupation of russia in
ukrainian territory
which is also a full member of this
organization
to acknowledge the efforts of the
secretary general
and his excellency
and your excellency in order to bring
dialogue and cooperation back to the
table at this difficult uh period for
humanity
as expressed by the president of the
jamaican republic
and i quote our country is shaken
by the military invasion
of russia against the people of ukraine
the russian federation
is violating the charter of the united
nations the minsk agreements and the
budapest memorandum as well as
countless resolutions of the security
council and of this very general
assembly
with this action
they are violating core principles of
international law
such as the respect for the territorial
integrity of states
the commitment to resolve the disputes
through peaceful means
and to refrain from
as well as respect for political
independence and non-interference in the
internal affairs of other states
the dominican republic a staunch
believer in peaceful coexistence between
peoples a defender of an international
legal framework which guarantees
fundamental rights
speaks out
by co-sponsoring this resolution
and
urgently
this world is solidarity and peace we do
not want any further deaths
hundreds of people
have been killed
and the humanitarian and economic
consequences are unpredictable
have the responsibility and the duty to
respect the charter of the united
nations
in the case of my country the dominican
republic these values are non-negotiable
as a founding member of these united
nations we will continue holding high
the democratic principles that brought
us all to san francisco in june of 1945.
we deplore
that today
we are discussing this painful topic
and we call on all delegations to firmly
and decidedly support the desire and
wish of ukraine and of all countries of
the world
to live in peace
today humanity is waiting for us let us
not fail
i thank the distinguished representative
of dominican republic
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of suriname
thank you mr president
mr secretary general
colleagues
the republic of suriname has taken note
with great concern of the russian
inflation in ukraine and strongly
condemns this military interface
intervention
supports the principles of international
law as enshrined in the charter of the
united nations and underscores the
independence and territory integrity of
ukraine
the russian invasion of a sovereign and
independent state cannot be accepted
and any on under any circumstance and
must stop immediately
this invasion will have far-reaching
consequences for the people of ukraine
and it is a serious threat to peace and
security both in the region and the
world
mr president in this regard the
government of the republic of suriname
would like to reiterate its principled
position with respect to the following
peaceful coexist co-existence the
re-establishment of dialogue in every
existing conflict regardless of its
nature
the upholding of the internationally
agreed principle of non-interference in
the internal affairs of states
non-intervention and respect for the
sovereignty and territory integrity of
states
a light of the above tsurinamo urges all
parties involved to engage responsibly
and practice restraint in order to
prevent destabilization of the region
mr president there are no winners in any
war war brings only human suffering and
devastation
suriname expresses its concern about the
humanitarian situation in ukraine and
calls upon all parties to allow and
facilitate the safe and unrestrained
access of humanitarian systems to those
in need
to protect civilians including those who
are humanitarian personnel and persons
in vulnerable situations
suriname welcomes the actions undertaken
by the secretary general
and and the united nations in disregards
and supports the secretary general's
call to end the war
mr president the republic of suriname
maintains diplomatic relations with both
russia and ukraine
and shall continue to call for processes
of dialogue and diplomacy which are
essential elements that contribute to
maintaining peace stability and security
i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of suriname
and i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of brunei
darussalam
mr president mr secretary general
brunei jerusalem expresses concern over
the escalation of tensions and military
actions in ukraine and continues to
closely monitor developments in the
country
brunei darussalam condemns any violation
of sovereignty independence and
territorial integrity of any country and
reiterates the importance of upholding
the principle of rule best framework and
respect of it for international law
finally brunei darussalam calls on all
parties directly involved to de-escalate
tensions and refrain from acts that may
aggravate the situation further and
settle all differences by peaceful means
without resorting to the threat or use
of force in accordance with the u.n
charter and international law in the
interest of maintaining international
peace and stability i thank you mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
brunei salam
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of palau
mr president secretary general
excellencies ladies and gentlemen palau
aligns itself with statement made by
fiji in its capacity as chair of the
pacific island forum we additionally
make the following statement in our
national
capacity ukraine and palau have little
in common one is a large post-soviet
state in eastern europe and the other is
a small blue ocean state an archipelago
of tropical islands in the pacific
yet we feel a certain kinship with
ukraine because we could be considered
close siblings in the birth of nations
ukraine became independent most recently
in 1991 and palau shortly thereafter in
1994
and it hasn't escaped us that if the
turns of fate had had one of our former
colonizers act with the aggression of
russia towards us that it would have
been our people who are suffering the
atrocities of war that's happening in
ukraine today
that it might have been my own
five-year-old that was killed in the kid
in kindergarten that was bombed
that it might have been a plow and
grandfather who fled his home with
nothing except the belongings on his
back
that it might have been a palauan woman
who would have been forced on what
should have been one of the most joyous
days of a woman's life to give birth in
a bomb shelter against the booming noise
of the missile strikes in the background
or finally that it might have been
hundreds of our civilians who would have
been killed in their homes
all in pursuit of putin's
self-proclaimed principle of historical
unity
as we look around the room few of us are
immune to historical unity as a
justification of war
in fact our colorful histories are often
the basis for the woven identities of
many of us
how many of us are former colonies and
or lived under a foreign rule at one
time or another
how many languages are spoken in our
countries and so on
our historical past is part of the
beauty of our fabric as an integrated
world
not a perverse excuse to wage an
unprovoked war on our neighbors
in this spirit palau asked for your vote
in favor of today's resolution to
condemn russia and its use of force
against ukraine
call your capitals make the case that we
must defend the u.n charter we cannot
stand by as russia looks to dismantle
the rules-based world order in pursuit
of its own self-interest
the german lutheran pastor martin
niemeler wrote the following while
reflecting on the danger of inaction in
world war ii
first they came for the socialists and i
didn't speak out because i was not a
socialist
then they came for the trade unionists
and i did not speak out because i was
not a trade unionist
then they came for the jews and i didn't
speak out because i was not a jew
then they came for me and there was no
one left to speak for me
ukraine palau stands with you we will
continue to speak out and fight for the
principles of the un charter human
rights and international law
we will continue to oppose the
inhumanity wrought by unjust illegal
warfare we call on all member states to
join us thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of palau
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of antigua
and barbuda
mr president
mr secretary general
colleagues
i stand before you
as a representative of the government of
antigua and barbuda
and we stand in solidarity
with the government and people
of ukraine
we're troubled
by the
invasion of ukraine
and we ask
our colleagues
member of this body
the russian federation
to cease the war and withdraw from
the territory of ukraine
mr president on february 8th
three weeks ago
the foreign minister of antigua in
barbuda noted
and i quote as a small country to which
territorial integrity self-determination
are vitally important
antigua and barbuda
are anxious
that these principles must be respected
and be upheld
everywhere
mr president when these principles are
threatened anywhere
our people
the global community has an obligation
to all countries big
or small
powerful or powerless
to speak out
and stand up
lest our silence be misconstrued as
consent
we recognize that the powerful country
of russia
has security gains over ukraine
but mr president
such concerns do not justify any attempt
at all to use force and to invade
against the country of ukraine and its
people
it's it and to [ __ ] its sovereignty
antigua and barbuda
believes in international peace and
security and adherence to international
law by all countries that's what we
stood for
this is central to our own security as a
small island state
we will not condone any any
act or the force of
in
invasion we will not condone the
violence the violation of the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
any country
therefore mr president we reject in the
strongest way possible
the use of force
that is currently being waged upon the
independent and sovereignty of the
country of ukraine we ask our friends
again to stop
and
remove all troops from the territory of
ukraine our small nation also recognizes
that
the conflict in ukraine plunges our
world further
into
a grave uncertainty with consequential
impacts on our entire global community
which is only now
recovering from the effects of the
pandemic
the con the conflict in ukraine has
derailed the discussion
on the recent report of the ipbcc
and takes away
much effort
that is needed to deal with the issues
of climate change
mr president
in the recovery
from the pandemic small states like mine
have seen according to ontad's report
essential goods increased
on an average of about 7.5 percent this
crisis only exacerbates the situation in
these island nations
this situation
must stop mr president
the crisis
for is this is a crisis for all of us
and we all must speak out
for diplomacy we all must support this
resolution it means as much to the small
states as the big states
my government fully supports the efforts
of the secretary general
and we urge
russia the russian federation to retain
return to the table and choose diplomacy
over confrontation
we as a small state would have hoped
that
the nations of the world had placed
conflict
before confrontation and that this was
was behind us we hoped that the use of
force to coerce some a sovereign nation
was a thing of the past we hoped mr
president that all countries of the
world had
had matured enough to accept
consultation over confrontation and
negotiations over provocation
we regret
colleagues that our friends in russia
have chosen
either or they are either unable or
unwilling
to follow the united nations charter and
the principles of this charter
to which they were a party
we asked that this war we cease and stop
mr president we were very disappointed
with the use of the veto
in which we trusted and enshrined in
the p5
this general assembly must stand up to
show that the use of the veto must not
be used selfishly
that
us
agreeing and supporting this resolution
calls for
a change in the way the veto is used mr
president we have heard that
the east and the west
argument this is not an east and west
argument this is a pivotal moment for
the united nations and if we stand up
and
show solidarity together we will change
the fork the vision that the east can do
one thing or the west can do one thing
and whenever this occurs again and we
hope never we will stand up against it
mr president antigua and barbuda fully
supports
the resolution that is before the house
and we call on all members especially
small island states to recognize that
this is protecting the principles of the
charter might is not right i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of antigua and barbuda
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of ghana
[Music]
mr president
mr secretary general
colleagues
let me begin by first of all thanking
the respective leadership of the
president of the general assembly
and the secretary general for convening
this emergency special session of the
general assembly
to consider the grave threat to
international peace and security
as a result of the russian federation's
aggression against ukraine
a member of this organization
we have met here
under the shadows of the dark clouds of
war in europe
we test the resolve of our diplomacy
and our collective ability to turn the
instruments of war into pillars of peace
the situation we are faced with in
ukraine is grave
and we all must acknowledge that
the foundations of trust that have made
the charter of the united nations
the indispensable instrument of the
international order
have been sealed in a reckless manner
in action on our part in randomly
condemning the actions of the russian
federation
and reaffirming our support for the
charter of our organization
and its collective security mechanism
would further undermine the pillars
that have held our world together
regardless of its imperfection
indeed across this hall
and throughout our organization's
history there's enough blame to go
around
when it has suited powerful states
the charter has been thrown out of the
window
and unlateral actions have been taken
without due regard
however
when old wounds are opened
it would bleed just as fresh wounds
it is in this regard and conscious
that there is never enough blame to make
us stand neutral to the course of peace
and the preservation of our united
nations
that we deem it our duty to make all
efforts for peace
the charter is our beacon of hope
and where states sell off
the turbulent waters of war and
destruction
we must point them back to the
lighthouse of peace
mr president as i said in the security
council on sunday afternoon
after the adoption of the resolution for
this emergency special session of the
general assembly
it is important that we come into this
debate with sobriety
this is not just our obligation to the
present generation and the civilization
we have fashioned
for our contemporary world
it is the debt and respect
we all to all those whose blood and toes
speak to us from the many graves of the
two world wars
we must mean it when we say
never again in our lifetimes and in
succeeding generations
should the world be put through the
sketch of war
the security council was constrained
from acting
and it is now our responsibility as an
assembly to act
and act we must
we should therefore support the call for
peace
from this hall the russian federation
must hear our call for an immediate
ceasefire
a withdrawal of its troops
from ukraine
and a recommitment to diplomacy and
dialogue
the parties to the conflict must respect
the principles of international law
international humanitarian law and human
rights law
the interest of civilian populations
must be placed above all else
and humanitarian agencies must be
granted safe corridors to assist those
most in need
especially children
women
and the
aged in this regard i know the dire
situation of 90 ghanaian students and
others
in sumi ukraine
and urge a humanitarian polls for them
and others in similar situations
to leave ukraine with the support of the
u.n agencies
and the international federation of the
red cross
like many others in this organization
ghana enjoys
long-standing relations of friendship
with the russian federation
but we have been fought right in our
condemnation
it takes true friendship to be candid
with one another
on matters of principles and values
to expect behavior
that greatness requires
the russian federation may well have had
the security concerns
but it chose to express its
concern in the wrong way
threatening the use of force is wrong
and unacceptable
threatening aggression is wrong and
unacceptable
and attacking a neighbor and that
pretext is wrong and unacceptable
the path of war is not the way one
should establish its national positions
and it is not an option this assembly
can accept
in condemning the aggression of the
russian federation however
we should not close off the path of
dialogue
ours is the vocation of peace
we must therefore recommend ourselves to
dialogue
to ensure that this war is ended
and as soon as possible
we are horrified by the brutal attacks
in ukraine
regret the many innocent lives that have
been lost
and are pained by their needless laws
from a war that was not necessary
we therefore call on ukraine
the russian federation and all other
parties
to give an opportunity for the dialogue
that since yesterday commenced at the
borders of belarus
without compromising ukraine's ineliable
rights
as a sovereign and independent nation
for ghana there is no doubt that our
commitment to ukraine is total
in the preservation of its sovereignty
political independence and territorial
integrity
we hope
that the adoption of this resolution
will make all parties to understand
that there is no option other than
dialogue in addressing the critical
situation we are confronted with in
ukraine
let us therefore say our bit in this
hall
but also deeply reflect on how outside
of this hall in our known capitals
and in other capitals we can recommend
the parties to dialogue and diplomacy
to avett the catastrophe of war
we have a responsibility to act as a
purveyors of peace
and that time is now i thank you very
much mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
ghana
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
federated states of micronesia
mr president mr secretary general
excellencies
we align ourselves with the statement
delivered by fiji
on behalf of the pacific islands forum
members
we endorse the efforts of the secretary
general
on the situation in ukraine
i would like to make these few points in
my national capacity
the events on the ground in ukraine have
dramatically worsened
in addition to the tensions in the
eastern part of ukraine
we are now seeing a full-fledged
invasion of a sovereign nation
an attack from a member of this
organization
on that of another member
this act is in full contravention
to international law
and the principles of our un charter
this is not a peacekeeping mission
but a war of aggression
it is clear beyond any doubt who is the
aggressor
and the victim
mr president
war has a human face
and there are no winners
it is with horror
that we witness
children
women
and civilians
fall victim
to this conflict
we deplore
this indiscriminate act
we call for the immediate secession of
hostilities
and the immediate withdrawal of russian
forces out of the sovereign territory of
ukraine and its internationally
recognized borders
and their immediate return to the
barracks
we further call
that rapid safe and unhindered access to
humanitarian assistance
and safe passage
be provided
to the ukrainian population and others
seeking
it mr president
micronesia is a small
and peace loving country
the principles
of our nation's constitution
which unites our micronesian island
nation
and its people
are closely related to the principles of
the united nations charter
we are encouraged by the strong
expressions and actions of the united
nations
particularly
those directed at the protection of
human rights as well as under
humanitarian law
and the prevention and suppression
of armed conflict
we are thus deeply concerned
by the abhorrent acts of the russian
federation
i cannot
overstress
our determination to stand united with
the people of ukraine
in solidarity
the federated states of micronesia
as announced
days ago by our president
has severe diplomatic relations with the
russian federation
mr president
diplomatic negotiations are needed in
good faith and on equal terms if peace
is to have a chance
we urge parties to take the path
for peaceful dialogue
we draw inspiration from the strength
and resilience of the
of the ukrainian people
in the face of overwhelming forces
micronesia stands in solidarity with
them
and we have co-sponsored and will vote
in favor of the draft resolution
aggression against ukraine i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of the federated states of micronesia
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
australia
mr president
secretary general
colleagues but particularly our dear
friend the ambassador of ukraine
my government could not have made its
position more clear
australia condemns in the strongest
possible terms russia's unprovoked
egregious
and completely unjustified aggression
against ukraine
as our prime minister has said
there is no pretext
there is no provocation
there is
no just cause
that russia is seeking to pursue
these are
unilateral
hostile actions
mr president
the u n charter
it says
we the peoples of the united nations
committed to unite our strength
to maintain international peace
and security
yet
russia has chosen war
we strongly reject any assertions or
excuses that russia's actions are
motivated by humanitarian concerns
we call russia's actions for what they
are
a brutal invasion and a direct attack on
the people of ukraine
president putin and the kremlin
have ignored repeated high-level calls
to engage in genuine reciprocal dialogue
over security
concerns as our foreign minister has
said
and i quote
the assertion by president putin of
russian soldiers acting as peacekeepers
is an obscene perversion of the noble
and vital role that generations of
peacekeepers have played across the
world
russia's actions
are deplorable
russia's actions are reckless and
destructive
russia's actions are a wholesale breach
of international law
mr president
let's be clear
russia is violating its obligations
under the un charter including most
obviously to refrain from using force
against another state
australia welcomed the significant
efforts that were made by our close
partners including the united states the
eu and nato to urge a diplomatic
solution
unfortunately those efforts have failed
for now
but we are determined to continue
to work closely within the un and with
responsible nations worldwide to ensure
russia's actions incur both the
international condemnation
and the high cost that they deserve
we welcome the significant steps taken
by our partners including the us the uk
the eu canada and japan
we also welcome the increasing number of
firm statements and practical offers of
support to ukraine
both in europe and in our own region of
the indo-pacific
the australian government has announced
a range of sanctions that impose real
costs on moscow reflecting the grave
nature of russia's conduct
australia has sanctioned more than 350
russian individuals including corrupt
oligarchs
mps and military commanders who are
facilitating putin's illegal and violent
ambitions
have sanctioned thirteen belarusian
individuals in entities who have aided
and abetted putin's aggression
we're also supporting ukraine and its
people
we're working with nato and other
partners to provide lethal
as well as non-lethal military equipment
medical supplies and financial
assistance to support the people of
ukraine
at the outset australia contributed
three million dollars to nato's trust
fund for ukraine to support non-lethal
military equipment and medical supplies
overnight our prime minister announced a
further 50 million dollars to support
both lethal and non-lethal defensive
support for ukraine working with our
partners
in addition the prime minister announced
an initial contribution of 25 million
dollars to provide
humanitarian support to international
organizations to help meet essential
needs and to provide shelter food
medical care and water
but this is just our opening
contribution
we know that needs will continue to rise
and we stand ready to help
we call on all parties to adhere to
international human rights and
humanitarian law to ensure the
protection of civilians
mr president
australia has been and will always be a
steadfast supporter of ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
our thoughts are with ukraine
ukrainians are enduring a terrible
invasion
the bombs fall
the shelling continues
the bullets are fired
special forces from russia are moving
towards cave
and tanks are rolling in all around
their borders
we reiterate our call
to stop this violation
we seek immediate withdrawal of the
russian military
we seek the cessation of this military
action
we call for peace
the peace that is not just the absence
of law
but that enables the people of ukraine
to live according to their own rules
according to their own sovereignty
and to have their own freedom
as the secretary general said last week
colleagues
the decisions of the coming days will
shape our world and directly affect the
lives of millions
now is the time for us all
the peoples of the united nations
to unite our strength
to maintain international peace and
security
australia will
co-sponsor the resolution
australia will vote yes on the
resolution
condemning russia's aggression
colleagues
now is the time to act
to act together
thank you colleagues
i thank the distinguished representative
of australia
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative guyana
mr president
mr secretary general
excellencies
the government of guyana fully aligns
itself
with the statements issued by the
caribbean community
on the 14th and 24th of february
and with the declaration of the
organization of american states
of the 25th of february
on the situation in ukraine
and wishes to re-emphasize the following
the government of guyana is gravely
concerned
over the recent military intervention
by russia
in violation of the territorial
integrity
and sovereignty of ukraine
and calls for an immediate cessation
of
hostilities and a return to diplomacy
guyana deplores the threat
or use of force
in the conduct of international
relations
and urges a peaceful resolution
of the differences that currently exist
in consonance with the rule of
international law
and the provisions of the united nations
charter
mr president the current military action
in ukraine
is contrary to the principles of respect
for territorial integrity
sovereignty
and the non-interference in the internal
affairs of another sovereign state
the aggression against ukraine
is a threat to the region
and countries everywhere
the government of guyana therefore
supports
the efforts of the united nations
secretary general
to bring a speedy resolution
to the situation in ukraine
and cease the threat to international
peace and security
in this regard
the government of guyana
fully supports the resolution before us
i thank you
[Music]
i thank the distinguished representative
guyana
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of jamaica
mr president
mr secretary general
thank you for convening this emergency
special session of the general assembly
during which we are considering the
unfolding situation in ukraine
jamaica strongly condemns the military
incursion into ukraine by the russian
federation
we call for the immediate
and complete withdrawal of russian
military forces
from the territory of ukraine
jamaica considers that the military
action by russia in ukraine violates the
principles enshrined in the un charter
both in word and in spirit
it undermines the core principles of
respect for sovereignty and territorial
integrity
the non-interference in the affairs of
sovereign states
and the obligation to refrain from the
threat or use of force
jamaica considers that these
are non-negotiable obligations to which
all of us as member states of this
united nations have subscribed
mr president
russia's actions over the last few days
are deemed as seriously egregious and
unjustifiable
especially given its position as a
permanent member of the united nations
security council
the very body mandated to maintain
international peace and security
by its actions russia is in clear
violation of its solemn duties and
responsibilities as a permanent member
of the security council and member of
the un family
we therefore call on russia to cease all
acts of aggression
and open all channels of diplomacy
to resolve this dispute peacefully
the global rules-based multilateral
system will be under threat if we do
nothing
as a small island state
jamaica recognizes that the
international legal framework
and the principles of the un charter are
designed to provide a safe environment
for all nations regardless of size and
stature
we cannot allow this international order
to be cast aside and ignored with
impunity
inaction by the global community would
be most egregious
we must stand up for right
for law
for peace
and demand the urgent cessation of
hostilities in ukraine and the return to
dialogue and diplomacy
as members of the united nations we have
all committed to save succeeding
generations from the scourge of war
that has too often brought untold sorrow
to mankind
the ongoing incursions in ukraine are a
violation of that sacred promise
military conflict has grave implications
for us all
jamaica notes with grave concern the
deteriorating humanitarian situation in
ukraine
and the impact on neighboring countries
and call on all parties to ensure that
displaced persons
both ukrainian and non-citizens and
including students and expatriates are
allowed safe and unfettered passage to
destinations outside ukraine
if they so desire
in this regard we welcome the secretary
general's announcement earlier of the
measures being undertaken to address
these humanitarian concerns
jamaica reaffirms the view that respect
for the principles of international law
and the un charter remain fundamental to
the maintenance of international peace
and security
it is only in such an environment that
we the peoples can continue to work to
address
and counter the most pressing challenges
that confront the world today and in the
future
mr president
as small states
we see too clearly the dangers of war
we feel too well
the threat of disruption of lives
livelihoods and economic devastation and
stagnation
in that sense
today
we are all
ukraine
we too
are fathers mothers
brothers and sisters
sons and daughters
in that sense too
today
we are all ukraine
in the internal and inspiring words of
bob marley therefore
let us get up
stand up stand up for the rights of all
the people of ukraine
because today
we are all ukraine i thank you
i know
i thank the distinguished representative
of jamaica
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative luxembourg
mr president
mr president
luxembourg
fully endorses the statement made
yesterday by the european union
please allow me to complement that
statement with some
some comments in my national capacity
in the face of war
we the members of the united nations
should all make our voice heard
russian armed forces continue to bomb
ukrainian towns and to break the lives
of an increasing number of
humans men women and children in ukraine
and at that time i would like to restate
the full solidarity of luxembourg with
the government and people of ukraine
like her european partners luxembourg
condemns in the strongest possible terms
russia's aggression against ukraine
[Music]
my country resolutely supports the
independence unity sovereignty and
torturing integrity of ukraine within
its internationally recognized borders
in line with the resolutions of the
general assembly
the brutal
unprovoked
carried out by the russian federation
against ukraine
a founding member of the united nations
is not just an attack on the
independence sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine
this aggression also
calls into question the very principles
of the united nations multilateralism
and the international order
founded on the rule of law and the
sovereign equality of states
in the face of such a situ
serious situation what can we do as the
united nations
because of russia's veto
the security council was not able to
take the decisions incumbent upon it
to fulfill its main responsibility for
the maintenance of international peace
and security
this came at a time when the draft
resolution presented last friday by
albania and the united states had the
support
of more than 80 member states from
around the world
luxembourg is grateful to the members of
the security council who voted the day
before yesterday in favor of resolution
2623
therefore allowing this
emergency special session of the general
assembly to take place
it is now incumbent upon the general
assembly to fulfill its responsibilities
luxembourg
is a co-sponsor and will vote in favor
of
the draft resolution entitled aggression
against ukraine
this is a strong resolution
it demands that russia immediately stop
using force against ukraine
that russia abstain from any threat or
illegal use of force
against any member of the united nations
and that it
withdraw immediately completely and
unconditionally
all of its military forces from ukraine
from within ukraine's internationally
recognized borders
the resolution also demands the
immediate peaceful settlement of the
conflict between the russian federation
and ukraine via political dialogue
negotiation
mediation and other peaceful means
colleagues voting in favor of this
resolution means voting to stop the war
voting to uphold the charter of the
united nations and international law
it means voting to save lives
to save the population in ukraine under
attack from russia
we call on all member states to vote in
favor of this draft resolution when it
is put to the vote
mr president
we are at a critical juncture for
security and stability in europe and
around the world
as the general stressed yesterday
nothing can justify the use
of nuclear weapons
we condemn belarus's involvement in the
aggression targeted at ukraine in
particular by making its territory
available to the russian armed forces
we demand that russia and belarus
instantly comply with international law
crimes should not go unpunished this is
particularly true
for war crimes and crimes against
humanity
in this respect
luxembourg welcomes the announcement
yesterday by the prosecutor of the
international criminal court that an
investigation will be opened imminently
into the situation in ukraine
the war in ukraine has a considerable
impact on the civilian population in
particular the most vulnerable
older people
women and children are paying
a very high price
the violations and attacks on human
rights are multiplied
luxembourg supports the efforts within
the human rights council to adopt a
resolution setting up an international
independent commission of inquiry
on ukraine
we call on russia to stop targeting
civilians and civilian infrastructure
including
by the european court of human rights
all possible measures should be taken by
the parties to protect civilians
including children
humanitarian personnel and also in
civilian infrastructure
international humanitarian law must be
respected
luxembourg expresses its gravest
possible concern about the humanitarian
situation in ukraine
and the increase in the number of
internally displaced persons and
refugees my country
joins the european and international
solidarity here and has decided to make
available to its humanitarian partners
immediate aid of one million euros
the authorities of luxembourg are also
preparing
to
host refugees
who are fleeing the war in ukraine
we are playing our full part in the
solidarity effort
and we hail the generosity
of the country's neighboring ukraine
who are already hosting hundreds of
thousands of refugees
the government of luxembourg has decided
to respond to the request of the
ukrainian authorities
and to provide them with rescue
equipment and with medicines through the
european civilian protection mechanism
as well as with equipment to build
ukraine's capacity
to defend itself
for the restrictive measures adopted by
the european union towards russia and
for measures of support with ukraine
with our european partners
we will continue to support ukraine on
the basis of respect for human dignity
for freedom
democracy
equality
the rule of law and the respect for the
human rights that we all share
president
colleagues the fate of ukraine is our
fate
the fate of ukraine is the fate of the
international rules-based order
we hail the courage of the president of
ukraine
of the ukrainian government and people
who are today fighting
for universal values
that the united nations was founded on
we also hailed the courage of russian
citizens who are showing their
opposition to the war
despite the repression of which they are
targets
like them we say to the leaders of the
russian federation
and i will now
switch to the language of pushkin to
russia
i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of luxembourg
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of papua
new guinea
mr president
mr secretary general
excellencies
distinguished delegates
papua new guinea feels the pain
and the hurt the people and the
government of ukraine are feeling at
this trying hour
and we stand in unity and solidarity
with all ukrainians in their court given
motherland
we welcome today's emergency
special session of the general assembly
and express our appreciation
to the security council members who made
it possible today
this should however
not have been the case had the very
security council entrusted and mandated
under the u.n charter for ensuring
global peace and security not failed us
to live up to its core responsibilities
in the context of ukraine
we are disappointed that some members of
the council whom we have entrusted our
support in good faith
for them to uphold the sacrosanct
principles of the u.n charter
in the council have failed us
looking the other way
at a critical moment concerning our
member state
space and security and also global peace
and security is not what we expected of
council members given that they do not
only represent
their own delegations interest in the
security council
it is time such as this
that yet again
brings to the fore
and underscores the urgency
for long overture reforms
of the video power
and archaic security council that
remains a prisoner of its past to the
detriment of our collective security
as has been regrettably witnessed in
ukraine
today
mr president
papua new guinea as a small developing
country
depends on the respect
for a rules-based international order
under international law including the
u.n charter the importance of upholding
this for all countries is fundamental
for peaceful coexistence
and international relations
no country respective of the economic
financial military clout has any right
to cause others
in shape or form
it is in this spirit that papua new
guinea is deeply concerned
by russian federation's aggressive
attack on the sovereignty territorial
integrity and independence of ukraine we
strongly deplore their actions
this must cease forthwith as it
contravenes the u.n charter and
international law particularly in the
context of a permanent member of the
security council as has been widely
underscored by the secretary general of
the united nations and many other
speakers delegations
we urge
for russia to withdraw immediately and
conditionally
from ukraine
we also encourage both parties to useful
peaceful dialogue
through diplomacy to resolve their
differences
we therefore welcome the efforts
underway
for dialogue and call for a safety and
security guarantees
for the peacemakers
rebuilding trust
confidence and mutual respect
within all constant parties cannot be at
the expense of accountability of actions
and actors
involved in this conflict
we also urge
for safe passage for humanitarian relief
workers
and suppliers to those in need of such
assistance in ukraine and education
countries and convey our gratitude for
their selfless work in a perilous
environment
we also thank neighboring countries of
ukraine for
opening their borders and hearts to
receive ukrainians and others seeking
refuge
mr president
it is for all this rationale
that my country papua new guinea
underservedly supports the secretary
general for being frank and forthright
on this issue
this is the right thing to do
we also fully support and endorse and
co-sponsor
the general assembly resolution
on ukraine
before us today
just as we also did for the security
council resolution last friday and
welcomed the uniting for peace
council resolution last saturday
in closing mr president we also align
ourselves
with the remarks with a statement
delivered
by fiji on behalf of the pacific islands
forum
and i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of
papua new guinea
and now i give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
timor-leste
mr president
excellencies timor-less is very
concerned with the current situation in
ukraine
as one of the last members who joined
the united nations in the last 20 years
timor-leste always believed in the
standards set by the united nations
charter that every state should uphold
the international law which govern the
rule of the rule-based order respecting
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
our state
what we have been witnessing in the past
few days are action taken
against international humanitarian and
human rights law
as this situation has escalated into a
full war and has taken a heavy toll on
the civilian population
for that very reason timor-leste
sponsored the security council draft
resolution calling for an end to this
situation which ultimately was not
adopted by a council
and now mr president
it is the general assembly duty to stand
up and defend the core foundation of the
united nations
timor-leste once again reaffirms its
commitment to upholding the principle of
international law and even charter by
sponsoring and fully supporting the
draft resolution of the general assembly
entitled aggression against ukraine
mr president
timothy understand the pain and
suffering caused by a military attack
as we have experienced it ourselves
as a nation that came from the assets of
forced occupation for years
timor-leste knows that war brings
benefit to no one
we therefore which party parties to the
conflict to agree to an immediate
ceasefire and to pursue a diplomatic
solution
while maintaining peace and security has
become the most crucial task of this
organization
we must protect the civilian population
and create condition for peace
we thank the secretary general
and all u.n agencies and partners for
their continued support to the civilian
population
through its humanitarian
cooperation efforts i thank you mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
of timor-leste
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative
vincent and the grenadians
mr president
excellencies
at the outset saint vincent and the
grenadines expresses
its deepest condolences to the families
of the victims who have lost their lives
due to the special military operation
launched by the russian federation in
the independent territory of ukraine
we continue to monitor the escalation of
the conflict and are deeply worried
by the deterior deteriorating situation
from our perspective
the special military operation
is neither necessary nor desirable
and is an affront to the united nations
charter
given the historical context
of the geopolitical situation in the
region and russia's articulation of its
legitimate security concerns
and perspective on the political
situation in the donbass region
we acknowledge the need for constructive
diplomatic efforts that thoroughly
address these concerns
the special military operation however
cannot reasonably be justified
it it only endangers
international peace and security and
will exacerbate human suffering across
the globe let us be clear
no member state of our organization will
be immune from the ripple effect of this
armed conflict
mr president
saint vincent and the grenadines is
unwaveringly committed to the purposes
and principles
of the united nations charter
including those relating to article 2
subsection 4
which prohibit
the threat or use of force against the
territorial integrity or political
independence of any state
as well as non-interference in the
internal affairs of states and the right
to self-determination
our existence as a sovereign and
independent small nation
is owed
to these international sacrosanct
sacrosanct norms and non-negotiable
timeless principles
accordingly
we cannot stand askance
while the bedrock principles of
international law are being jettisoned
and call for the immediate cessation of
all hostilities
we specifically urge this strict
adherence
to the principles of sovereignty
political independence territorial
integrity non-intervention
non-interference respect for human
rights and international humanitarian
law
equally
we reiterate the recent calls
made by the caribbean community caricom
and the organization of eastern
caribbean states oecs for these pacific
settlements of disputes
and the respect
of ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
mr president
historically
the russian federation has been a
defender of the purposes and principles
of the united nations charter inclusive
of the sacred principle of the peaceful
settlement of disputes
this is emblematic of its membership in
the group of friends in defense of the
united nations charter
as a fellow defender of these principles
and member of this group
saint vincent and the grenadines
unequivocally insists that the russian
federation cease
its military operations and immediately
withdraw its forces from ukraine
on countless occasions we have witnessed
the insidious effects of interventionism
and external aggressions across the
developing world
and we know that constructive dialogue
in adherence to international law
is the only path
to peace and progress
however difficult that path may be we
deeply regret
that the minced agreements have been
violated
we also make an appeal for meaningless
meaningful diplomatic initiatives and
encourage the furtherance of the work of
the normandy format the trilateral
contact group and the organization for
security and cooperation in europe
we urge the parties to exhaust all
diplomatic efforts
to find a peaceful solution
to the current conflict
we firmly believe
that the nobility of peace is far
preferable than an ignoble military
adventure
history has taught us that peace is a
great cause
and great causes
have never been won by doubtful men and
women
while we are encouraged by the recent
meeting
that was held on the belarusian border
between both sides
we must put on record
that the use of nuclear weapons is
inconceivable and wholly unacceptable
we counsel against the mayor's
suggestion
by anyone
we counsel further
that space for continued
dialogue must remain open
before i conclude mr president i would
it will be remiss of me
not to express my dismay
for the disturbing reports that people
of african descent
are being singled out to unfair
treatment as they join the masses
fleeing the ukrainian territory
in line with international humanitarian
law
and its guiding principles we call on
all states to uphold
their international obligations and
ensure the safety of all peoples
in conclusion mr president st vincent
and the
grenadines repeats that it is a stout
champion of the purposes and principles
of the united nations charter and their
primacy in our multilateral system
we must and i repeat we must give peace
a real chance to succeed
we must stop this war and return
to diplomacy
thank you and peace profound to all
i thank the distinguished representative
of saint vincent and the grenadians
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of monaco
mr president
president of the general
assembly i wish to recall that the
principality of monaco endorses the
statement made by the european union
yesterday
on the 28th of february
i wish to restate from this high roster
that my country is committed to respect
for international law
and the u.n charter
in this forum
where each state has one voice or one
vote rather in line with the principle
of sovereign equality enshrined in the
charter
monaco
will use its vote
to support ukraine
committing to the charter in good faith
disputes through peaceful means
not attacking the territorial integrity
of a state
these are the fundamental principles
that
every member state signs up for in
becoming a member of the united nations
mr president we deplore the increasing
number of victims and are gravely
concerned that the population is being
displaced as they flee violence
as well as being concerned for the more
than 600 000 people who are already
refugees
the situation is worsening rapidly
civilians are suffering and in the face
of this we call for respect for
international humanitarian law and
recall that the geneva conventions and
their additional protocols
impose a distinction between civilians
and combatants
and
ban
using civilians as targets
we call also for unimpeded access for
humanitarian assistance
we remain convinced that dialogue based
on international law
and the principles and values of the
charter
are the only way of finding an end to
this war that concerns all of us
this may seem trivial but on the 2nd of
december 2021 the general assembly
adopted a resolution on the olympic
truce
the winter paralympic games opened
on the 4th of march 2022 and we
condemned the violation of this symbol
of friendship and fraternity between
peoples
monaco defends the multilateral system
and advocates peace
monaco co-sponsors the draft resolution
entitled aggression against ukraine
which is submitted for the consideration
of the general assembly meeting in an
emergency special session
monaco will vote in favor of this text
i thank the distinguished representative
monaco
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of spain
the
statement of the delegation of the
european union on behalf of the union
and this member
president the general assembly is
meeting
because the security council has been
blocked
by the veto of the russian federation
to carry out the tasks of
maintenance of peace
and peaceful settlement of
possibly disputes
charged
by the charter absolutely
members of the security council who made
this special
meeting possible and it is now up to all
member states to defend peace
and the united nations
when it exercises veto russia explained
that it is doing so to balance the
interests
of the
permanent members of the council
is that balance of interest
interpreted by just one of the apartment
members more important than the
principles and values of the charter
are all member states for the united
nations equally sovereign or some more
equal than others with the right to
unilaterally impose an interpretation of
the charter
spain deplores the use of veto by russia
which has prevented
the
adoption of the resolution co-sponsored
by 82 member states including spain
the veto is an anachronism
we must get rid of it
the defense of an international order
based on international law and the
principles and values of the charter
cannot be conditioned by
[Music]
which was invaded by the russian
federation of the cooperation of belarus
the defense of peace
and the pacific settlement and
diplomatic settlement of conflicts
but also
the very reason why our multilateral
organization the united nations exists
spain roundly condemns the russian
invasion of ukraine he acknowledges
sovereignty independence
and territorial integrity of ukraine
hours and days have passed since the
attack of the russian federation against
uk
but ukraine is resisting and continues
to resist as the world watches admiring
them well aware of how unequal the
struggle is
every minute of resistance makes the
attacker's self justification vanish
into thin air
how can we deny
in the name of an empire
overthrown by russian citizens
themselves
the right to the independence of ukraine
at the same time as it is
it is being attacked in the name of the
independence of the dumbass region
how can we allege security uh
interests declaring a state of high
alert
for nuclear tactical forces which is the
greatest threat possible against
collective security
as if these reasons were not enough to
vote
for the resolution uh presented to the
general assembly anybody imagine what
hope there would be
a ceasefire
this resolution did not have an
overwhelming majority
does anybody believe
that contacts would continue
without uh
preconditions between the
representatives of ukraine the russian
federation
what would it uh what could we put
under
the aegis of
when it comes to future negotiations for
a collective security system
humanitarian action
moral support were there before
humanitarian assistance to
unconditionally help our victims of the
of the war how would it be funded and
protected what support would there be
for the indispensable good officers that
secretary general
uh offers
president colleagues enough of war we
usually call for an immediate ceasefire
withdrawal of russian troops from
ukraine
yes returned to the diplomatic part that
was open until the security council of
last february 23rd
contacts between ukraine the russian
federation was situated a diplomatic
negotiation
which when the good officers and
secretary general guterres will lead to
the end of a conflict and lasting peace
the resolution we will vote for in this
general assembly with all of its
imitations
and uh
virtues
has become a symbol of hope of future
based on multilateralism the sovereign
equality of states the peaceful
settlement of disputes and peace it has
become a living test major charger that
is all vote for it thank you
for spain
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of belize
mr president
excellencies
all members of the united nations are
obligated to refrain in their
international relations from the threat
or use of force against the territorial
integrity or political independence of
any state
the invasion of ukraine by russia is a
blatant breach of russia's obligation
under united nations charter
it constitutes an unacceptable violation
of ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
and contravenes article 2.4 of the u.n
charter and the norms and principles of
international law
the attack by russia and the republic of
rurkin is therefore an attack on the
charter and an attack on the
international system
we therefore strongly and inequitably
condemn the russian illegal attack on
ukraine and its close violation of
international law
mr president we are extremely concerned
about the devastative impact that this
illegal war is having on the lives of
ukrainians
already loss of life
disruption of livelihoods destruction of
property and terror are occurring in the
republic of european
war leaves permanent cars on society the
impact is being felt especially hard by
women and children
the elderly and persons with disability
a generation of ukrainians will be lost
and families forever destroyed
mr president we need to consider a
situation of war in the 21st century
we all agreed to leave wars behind when
the second world war ended an
international community created the
united nations organization
to ensure that the peoples of the world
would never again suffer this courage of
war
we all agreed to and signed the united
nations charter and committed to uphold
its principles
we created an organization to provide a
forum where the tools for peaceful
settlement of disputes are available for
all member states
a forum where diplomacy and
international law should prevail over
armed conflict
we remain resolute that allstate must
respect and adhere to the principle of
the charter of the united nations
and the norms of international law which
are fundamental to the maintenance of
international system and peace and
security
including respect for sovereignty
territorial integrity within
international recognized borders
non-interference in the internal affairs
of another state
and the prohibition and the threat or
use of force for the resolution of
disputes
mr president in unison
with the sentiment expressed by others
we call for an immediate secession of
hostilities the withdrawal of all
russian troops and military hardware
from the occupied territories in ukraine
we urge all sides to re exercise the
stream allow the safe passage of all
civilians
comply with international humanitarian
law and to resort to diplomacy to find a
solution to this international armed
conflict
belize stands in solidarity with ukraine
and its people who are enduring the
tragedy of war i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of belize
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of south
africa
mr president
excellencies
south africa remains deeply concerned
by the escalation of the conflict
in ukraine
we welcome the commencement of talks
between ukraine and russia
we hope that these discussions
will lead to a diplomatic solution
that will result in a sustainable
political solution
south africa is of the view that this um
conflict
like all others
will result in unnecessary human
suffering
and destruction
with global ramifications
in situations of conflict the most
vulnerable tend to suffer the most
during
and post the conflict
it is regrettable that at the time when
the world is struggling to emerge from
the effects of covet 19 pandemic
we assist with a conflict
that will further delay the world's
recovery
the u.n secretary general
guterres
reminded us of this when he stated that
the conflict
will have a huge impact on the global
economy
in a moment when we are emerging
from the covet-19 pandemic
and so many developing countries need to
have the space for recovery
the un was founded after the men after
the horus of the second world war
with the aim
of saving succeeding generations from
the sketch of war
it is for this reason
that the charter of the united nations
enjoins all member states
to settle
that dispute by peaceful means
in such a manner that international
peace
security
and justice are not endangered
mr president we stress that peace is
best built through diplomacy and
dialogue
within the framework of the institutions
of global dialogue especially the united
nations
it is important
for all nations to respect and uphold
the principles of international law
including international humanitarian law
and the provisions of the u.n charter
the u.n is now in its 76th year of
existence
and the events of the last two weeks
have again
reminded us
of the urgent need to reform the u.n
especially the u.n security council
which is long
overdue we need a council free from the
legacy of the cold war
so that it can genuinely be the space
where the community of nations come
together
to resolve conflict
and build a more just
and peaceful world
mr president south africa always
appreciates the value that dialogue has
in averting a crisis and de-escalating
conflict
this is in line with our strong
commitment to the peaceful resolution of
conflict
in this regard
we also urge the security council
to utilize existing tools at this
disposal
in support of the pacific settlements of
disputes
we also
believe that the good offices of the u.n
secretary general could make a positive
contribution in finding a lasting
solution to this conflict and should be
utilized
we just we urge all parties to approach
the situation in a spirit of compromise
with all sides upholding human rights
abiding by their obligations under the
international law and international
humanitarian law
a diplomatic solution to the problem
should address
the security concerns of the parties
south africa continues to support
and encourage regional initiatives such
as the minsk agreement
and we welcome the work of the normandy
format
the trilateral contact group
and the organization for security and
cooperation in europe
mr president this meeting is being held
under the uniting for peace formula
which requires the general assembly to
meet if and when the security council is
unable to act
however it remains necessary for the
security council to exercise its
responsibility fully in the current
situation
the situation in ukraine
should not be allowed mr president to
affect negatively other priorities of
the international community and the rest
of the work of the united nations we
therefore note with concern that not all
situations of conflict have received the
same attention
indeed while there is this focus on
ukraine
long-standing situations that the
security council assist with continue
without resolution
it is necessary that we devote equal
attention to other long-standing
conflicts
where the u.n charter
and the human rights
are being violated
in conclusion
south africa endorses the statement
issued by the african union commission
expressing concern
that the treatment at the treatment
given to african nationals and people
african descent at the borders of
ukraine
some of whom are not allowed to cross
and move to safety
we urge european countries to take steps
to resolve the situation
as all people have a right to cross
international borders during times of
conflict
i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of south africa
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of gabon
a clear message to the peoples of the
world
our message
is that the united nations are against
women
by doing this we are playing our role
this organization
the general assembly should
unambiguously
[Music]
all
this general assembly should make its
voice heard with force
weapons are being used in
ukraine blood is flowing and thousands
of innocent civilians men women and
children are fleeing their houses their
towns and their country
to seek refuge elsewhere
as members of the international
community
should be unequivocal
in its rejection of belligerence
until the spectre
of confrontation recedes
and until there is a peaceful resolution
of the conflict
we have the duty to offer an alternative
to fear
there is still time
there is always time
to choose dialogue
and diplomacy over force
is deeply committed to peace
[Music]
my country believes in multilateralism
it believes in international
all of its
relevance and nobility on our
organization
and that is why we are calling for an
immediate ceasefire and a de-escalation
of the conflict
we call on all of the parties to return
to dialogue
and
to abstain from any use of weapons
whose effect is indiscriminate
access to humanitarian aid for the
population that needs it should be
unimpeded and should be given without
discrimination
we
raised by african students fleeing the
war in ukraine and who are finding
discrimination in trying to seek shelter
this situation is unacceptable
we say no to racism
resolution submitted for our
consideration
my country supports international peace
and security
and we stress
the concerning nature
of the assaults on our shared values
against which we sometimes feel
powerless and against the selective
respect for certain principles of the
u.n charter thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of gabon
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
cuba
senor president
president
expressing clearly
its position
for a solution which will guarantee the
safety and sovereignty
of all concerned and that will respond
to legitimate humanitarian concerns
cuba is a country that defends
international law it is committed to the
charter of the united nations
cuba will always defend peace
and
ambiguously respond to the threat or
use of force against any state
for this reason
we firmly support
the proclamation of america latin
america and the caribbean is the zone of
peace signed by heads of state
to protect the population their goods
and civilian infrastructure
we deeply deplore the losses of life of
innocent civilians in ukraine
the cuban people has had and continues
to have a close relationship with the
people of ukraine
it is not possible to rigorously and
honestly
analyze the current situation in ukraine
without
carefully considering the factors
that have led to the use of force
and the non-observance of legal
principles and international standards
cuba
for the supports of these
principles
which is upholds
and considers that they are an
indispensable reference particularly for
small countries
against hegemony
the abuse of power and injustice
the united states determination
to continue
the progressive expansion of nato
towards the
uh borders of the russian federation
have led
to
a scenario
with unpredictable scope but which could
nevertheless have been avoided
the military movements made by the
united states
and nato in recent years
are well known
in their movement towards the regions
adjacent to the russian federation
preceded by the delivery of modern
weapons to ukraine
which
is
the equivalent of a military peninsula
it was a mistake to ignore the russian
federation's demands for security
guarantees
and
it was a mistake to suppose that it
would remain
inactive in the face of a threat to its
national security
it is not possible
to achieve peace
surrounding
because of its doctrine of increasingly
offensive military
policy outside the borders of nato which
threatens international peace and
stability and security
our concerns are heightened by the
recent decision of nato
to activate for
it must be recognized the united states
european country which they broke up at
a high cost of lives
for their geopolitical
purposes
whilst ignoring the charges of the
united nations
the united states and allies have used
force on multiple occasions invading
sovereign states
to trigger
regime change
and interfering in the internal affairs
of other nations
that do not bow to their interests of
domination
and
who defend their territorial integrity
and independence
they are also responsible for the deaths
of hundreds of thousands of civilians
they describe as collateral damage
millions of displaced people and vast
destruction
across the face of our planet
as a result of their wars of pillage
and plunder
present
resolution on the situation
in ukraine
which was not approved in the security
council last february 25th
was not seen
was not designed as a real
search for solutions to the current
crisis
the text submitted to the general
assembly today
suffers from the same deficiencies
and lack of balance
it does not take into account the
legitimate concerns of all parties
concerned
nor does it acknowledge
the responsibility
of those
who
took aggressive actions
which precipitated the escalation of
this conflict
we welcomed
are the only way to resolve this
conflict
cuba will continue
advocating a diplomatic
solution which is serious constructive
and
realistic for the current crisis
in europe through peaceful means that
will guarantee the freedom and
sovereignty of all
as well as peace stability
and regional
and international stability thank you
very much
i thank the distinguished representative
of cuba
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of samoa
mr president excellencies
samuel aligns itself with the statement
delivered by fiji
on behalf of the pacific island forum
and i wish to add the following remarks
in my national capacity
samoa stands in solidarity with the
people of ukraine
as a peace loving
and vulnerable small island state
samoa believes that there are only a few
global mechanisms
available
to safeguard our security
continue existence
and well-being
one of these lies in the maintenance of
global peace
and the respect
for rule-based international order
the preamble of the eu
and charter highlights
as one of its key results
of our organization and i quote
is to save successful generation from
this court to war
and to leaving peace with one another as
good neighbors
colleagues
that must be our main focus now
as members of the un family
samoa is greatly concerned
by the invasion of ukraine by the
russian federation
such action is in clear violation of the
territorial integrity
and sovereignty of ukraine
and inconsistent with the stated
principles laid out
in article 2
of the u.n charter
we condemn
russia's unprovoked
attack
on ukraine
samoa strongly advocates for peace
and urge all actors involved to focus
their efforts
on ensuring an immediate cessation of
hostilities
protection of civilian
and civilian infrastructure
reframing
from actions that may further escalate
the dangerous and delicate situation in
ukraine
seize all
military operation and return to the
barracks
and prioritize diplomacy
to diffuse
tension
the current call by both ukraine and
russia for peace talk
is therefore most welcome
we join the chorus of call by other
delegation on russia to respect
the founding principle of the u.n
charter
abide by the principle of international
law
state sovereignty and territorial
integrity
and fully honor
the minsk agreement
as adopted by the security council
in 2015
mr president
samuel strongly support
the statement made by the secretary
general last week
and yesterday
samoa may be a small state
but it is our moral obligation to speak
up
and to be counted
for the principle upon which
we have all subscribed to
let us all give peace a chance
and support the un draft resolution
some more will co-sponsor
and vote yes thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
some more
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative philippines
[Music]
mr president
the philippines will vote yes
to the unga resolution
and expresses explicit condemnation of
the invasion of ukraine
no one can trust news reports of
casualties on either side
but since 2014 14 000 have been killed
in the current fog of lies we have yet
to determine the true casualties on both
sides
we appeal for the protection of
civilians and civilian infrastructure
we strongly urge the cessation of
facilities
but while an offense can be stopped at
will
the defense cannot rest until it does
we call for massive assistance
commensurate with the growing
humanitarian crisis
and echo the u.n secretary general's
appeal for respect of humanitarian
principles to protect civilians and
civilian infrastructures in ukraine
safe access to humanitarian assistance
must be assured by the most effective
means
the principle of sovereignty and the
sovereign equality of states is
enshrined in the u.n charter
all states enjoy the right to full
sovereignty in all their areas of
jurisdiction
the charter of the united nations
requires sovereign states to refrain
from the use of force against the
political independence and territorial
integrity of any state
we especially condemn the use of
separatism and secession as a weapon of
diplomacy for inviting and inflicting
terrible cruelties and indiscriminate
killings
far in excess of that of any other kind
of conflict we saw this in the balkans
and africa
we strongly urge resort to the 1982
manila declaration on the peaceful
settlement of international disputes
it will at least halt the ongoing
tragedy for a while i thank you mr
president
i thank the distinguished representative
of philippines
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of cabo
verde
uh
mr president
colleagues
the government of cabo verde has been
following with deep and growing concern
the unfolding developments in ukraine
as of february 24th
since the beginning of the military
invasion of russia
pursuing the recognition of two
ukrainian regions
in fact we are witnessing an escalade
leading to the worst
and dangerous
scenario of an urban guerrilla
in the big cities in ukraine
predicting the high death tolls
fracturing societies and grimming a
postponed future of a generation
capo verde commends the convenience of
this ga
giving to all members the possibility to
position
vis-a-vis the intensification of this
senseless
and fratricide war
this is a defying
and private moment for un and for
humanity
thus we praise the initiatives of the
secretary-general and some member states
on humanitarian aid
and urge for an immediate launch of the
operations in the field
in order to save lives
especially of the more vulnerable
the fleeing people
and the refugees
to whom basic human rights
rights are defaulting
we commend the efforts of the
neighboring countries
and urge them to facilitate the entry
of all citizens
fleeing from ukraine
we are facing a scenario that represents
the biggest global challenge
and threat to international peace and
security
that calls into question the security
and well-being
of the vulnerable civilian people
which is already triggering political
economic
and social consequences not only in
eastern europe but also in the rest of
the world
mr president
cabo verde inequivocally condemns
the recourse of to threat or the use of
force in the relations between states
and pledges for the respect of the
values and international law
enshrined in the united nations charter
in these regards it reiterates the need
to observe the principles of sovereign
equality
territorial integrity and unviability of
the states
so let's not fail
tackling this serious challenge to
multilateralism and prompt a response
aiming to stop and revert the situation
honoring the universality of the u.n
charter
being a small island developing state
cabo verde attaches paramount importance
to the strict strict observance of the
charter's principles and content
it is existential for us
a safeguard for international peace and
security
instrumental in the context of ongoing
multi-dimensional crises
at the outset of the decade of action
already with a pandemic induced setback
in the dynamic of implementation of the
agenda 2030
hampering and putting in risk
the consistency of the ongoing timid
global recovery trend
on this basis we firmly believe that no
effort should be spared
to an immediate ceasefire
as well as to seek a diplomatic way out
through dialogue and negotiations for
conflict resolution
under the provisions of minsk agreement
in coherence with the resolution
2202 of the security council
the i the ongoing direct talks at the
belarusian border
although late
comes at the right direction
we are shocked by what's happening in
ukraine
we banned ourselves
in face of the heroism of the ukrainian
people
to whom we present our condolences
on the other hand
being a long-standing friend of russia
we have to beg her to stop the killing
of innocent people
let's stop this war that's enough
peace to prevail cabo verde will vote
for the resolution
and thank you mr chairman
i thank the distinguished representative
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of hungary
mr president
excellencies dear colleagues
while we align ourselves with the
statement delivered by the european
union i wish to make the following
remarks in my national capacity
mr president
hungary reaffirms its unwavering support
for ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
the u.n charter is clear
it unequivocally prohibits the use of
force against the territorial integrity
and political independence of states
and also urges that states settle their
international disputes by peaceful means
in such a manner that international
peace and security and justice are not
endangered
we subscribe to the message delivered by
the secretary general on this issue
that the decision of the russian
federation is a violation of the
sovereignty and territorial integrity of
ukraine
and inconsistent with the principles of
the charter of the united nations
mr president
hungary condemns
russia's military intervention against
ukraine and a serious escalation we all
witnessed during last week including the
threat to use nuclear weapons
hungary condemns the recognition of the
non-governmental controlled areas of
donetsk and luhansk oblasts of ukraine
as independent entities
and the subsequent decision to send
russian troops into ukraine
this aggression against the sovereign
u.n member state is deeply concerning
as this illegal act further undermines
ukraine's sovereignty and independence
and is a severe breach of international
law and international agreements
war
is the worst possible scenario which we
hoped to never have to experience again
in our neighborhood
we regret that the diplomatic efforts
failed
to bring a peaceful conclusion of the
tensions
peace and stability is threatened in
europe and worldwide
what is happening in ukraine
affects the security of each and every
un member state
in this situation we need strategic
calmness
we have to avoid actions that further
escalate the already dire situation
mr president
as for hungary
the war in our neighboring country is a
great security risk
therefore we are interested in achieving
a peaceful conclusion to this conflict
and we have to also preserve channels of
communication in order to maintain the
chance for negotiations
hungary as a central european country is
genuinely interested in east-west
dialogue
in our region has always suffered as a
consequence of conflict between the
power struggle of the powerful nations
we have not forgotten the experience of
the cold war
we welcome news of direct negotiations
between the parties and hope that they
may lead to a restoration of peace in
our neighborhood
we strongly support eu and nato unity on
this issue and support our joint
responses to the situation
hungary underlines its support for the
existing international frameworks for
the sustainable and peaceful resolution
of conflicts in accordance with
international law and in particular with
the osce commitments
hungary also expresses its support for
the valuable engagement of the osce
special monitoring mission and its
tremendous efforts of gathering and
reporting facts in an extremely
challenging situation
mr president
in response to the evolving humanitarian
crisis
hungary is ready and fully mobilized to
receive refugees who need help or
shelter during the ongoing aggression
our ambassadors are open
and we are operating our border crossing
stations with full capacity
many third countries have requested help
from us in evacuating their citizens
we have allowed entrance for all people
fleeing from war without any
restrictions and without discrimination
as to race ethnicity religion or country
of origin
we affirm that all cases of
discrimination will be thoroughly
investigated and perpetrators held
accountable
we have established a humanitarian
corridor in order to facilitate the
entrance of the citizens of these
countries to hungary without a visa
and then we help them make their way to
the nearest airport from where they can
safely return to their home countries
mr president
even though the situation on the ground
is deeply worrying we believe that there
is a diplomatic solution to this
conflict to that end we urge for the
immediate cessation of all hostilities
and the resumption of negotiations
i reiterate the proposal made by the
hungarian minister foreign affairs and
trade mr peter ciarto to offer budapest
hungary's capital as a venue for such
diplomatic efforts
we hope that the parties accept this
invitation and participate in talks with
good faith and a willingness to
peacefully resolve the crisis and end
the war
to conclude mr president
hungary is deeply worried by the war
that is occurring in our neighboring
country
we are also worried
that it may have security humanitarian
political and economic ramifications on
a global scale
hungary again
reaffirms her unwavering support for
ukraine's territorial integrity
political independence and sovereignty
let me reiterate once again our firm
believe that tensions and disagreements
must be resolved through dialogue and
diplomacy especially in a conflict of
disco
the resolution
is not about taking side it is about
upholding the principles of the u.n
charter it is about peace
hungary will vote yes on this resolution
and encourage you all to do the same
i thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
of hungary
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of malta
mr president
malta fully aligns itself with a
statement delivered by the european
union and would like to make some
additional remarks in its national
capacity
malta reiterates its unwavering support
for the sovereignty territorial
integrity and independence of ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
we express our heartfelt condolences to
the families of the victims who have
lost their lives because of this
unprovoked war by the russian federation
which we strongly condemn
this decision is illegal and
unacceptable it is a violation of
international law
it is a violation of the un charter it
is a violation of ukraine's sovereignty
and territorial integrity it is a
violation of russia's own international
commitments
mr president malta fully agrees with the
secretary general's view that this
military offensive is a reputation of
the principles of the un charter
the foundations of the un rest on the
sovereignty and independence of states
principles that we have all agreed to
and that we all depend upon
threats to the territorial integrity of
states and international law are not
confined to one region but have
ramifications for the security of all
countries
last week malta joined a group of over
80 countries to co-sponsor a resolution
tabled by the united states and albania
condemning the russian federation for
its aggression and calling on it to end
its offensive
regrettably the security council was not
able to fulfill its duty because a
permanent member vetoed the resolution
even more disturbing is the fact that
the permanent member casting the veto is
also the aggressor
mr president this war has already had a
devastating impact on the lives of
civilians
we stress that international
humanitarian law must be respected at
all times and that the protection of
civilians is a fundamental principle
we also call for the facilitation of
rapid safe and unhindered humanitarian
assistance to those in need
malta calls for the immediate withdrawal
of russian forces from ukraine and
emphasizes the need to avoid a dangerous
escalation in europe it is never too
late for diplomacy
we underline once again the serious
breaches of the un charter are a matter
of global concern and as such we hope
the general assembly will send a
unanimous signal to the world by
defending the very principles on which
these united nations were built and
underlining the sovereignty and
independence of all member states
malta will never accept a situation
where might is right thank you
i thank the distinguished representative
malta
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative malaysia
mr president
malaysia is seriously concerned over the
escalation of military conflict in
ukraine
malaysia regrets the inability of this
city council
in exercising its primary responsibility
for the maintenance of international
peace and security
hence the necessity of this emergency
special session
of the un general assembly
we are at crossroads and we understand
the legitimate security concerns of all
parties
nevertheless in any circumstances
all parties must abide and respect the
principle of sovereignty and territorial
integrity of all states
as enshrined in the u.n charter and
international law
any violation of this sacrosanct
principle
is unacceptable
it is clear that in conflict situations
no solutions can be found at the end of
the barrel of a gun
at this critical juncture we call on all
parties to exercise restraint
take concrete steps to de-escalate
and pursue dialogue to resolve
the conflict peacefully
malaysia therefore welcomes
the direct talks between ukraine and
russia in belarus yesterday
we hope that the talks will continue
and bring about a speedy resolution to
the conflict to prevent further loss of
lives and devastation
malaysia also calls on all parties to
refrain from taking unilateral actions
that may aggravate tensions and have
far-reaching regional and global
consequences
we are also deeply concerned
on reports about nuclear arsenals
being put on high alert status we call
on all nuclear weapon states to adhere
to their joint statement of january 2022
on preventing nuclear war and avoiding
arms races
malaysia fully supports the affirmation
that a nuclear war cannot be won
and must never be fought
we further urge nuclear weapons states
to pursue actions
towards the alerting risk reduction and
to implement their commitments and
obligations
related to nuclear disarmament and
non-proliferation
with the dire situation on the ground
malaysia urges all parties to ensure
the protection and well-being of the
people in particular women children and
other vulnerable segments of society
this must also be our immediate priority
in this context we call on all parties
to respect the relevant provisions of
international humanitarian and human
rights laws
mr president
malaysia is also speaking today
having suffered the consequences of the
conflict in ukraine
with the downing of malaysia airlines
flight mh17
eight years ago
298 innocent lives were lost in that
tragedy
we continue to remember and mourn them
we will also continue joint efforts with
our partners to seek
justice and accountability in accordance
with the rule of law
and in line with the u.n security
council resolution 2166 of
2014. conclusion malaysia reiterates our
commitment
to the peaceful settlement of dispute
guided by the principal enshrine in the
u.n charter and international law
in the interest of maintaining regional
and international peace and security
as well as promoting greater prosperity
in this connection malaysia will vote in
favor of the draft resolution
which is now before the assembly i thank
you
i thank the distinguished representative
malaysia
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
kuwait
the name of god the compassionate the
merciful mr president
the general assembly today is discussing
the matter of the security council
inability to discharge its duty to
maintain
peace and security in europe and in the
world
the multilateral international
system based on the respect for
international law and
the u.n charter
is passing through a delicate stage
which represents a real test for the
united nations to defend the values and
principles on which it was
founded for more more than 76
years ago
the
developing unfolding situation in
ukraine led to the killing and
injury of
hundreds of people
as well as the displacement
of so many others require
of us
taking a steadfast and immediate stand
to resolve disputes by peaceful means
we
hail here the
negotiations held yesterday between
russia and ukraine and belarus as a
glimmer of hope and we hope this will be
followed by other sessions that will
lead to
peaceful settlement of that conflict
kuwait has
a small
country given our
painful experience in 1991
occupied at the time
it upholds its principal positions to
abide by international law and the u.n
charter
which represents safe haven for small
states to maintain their sovereignty
territorial integrity and independence
embodying the
among states and we abide by the u.n
charter and its principles that govern
and regulate
relations among the states
based on respect for their sovereignty
territorial integrity and independence
within their internationally
acknowledged recognized
borders non-interference in their
internal affairs and solving conflicts
by peaceful means
here we would like to reiterate
our uh
support for the territorial integrity
and sovereignty of
an independence of
ukraine
we call upon the parties to abide by uh
resolution 2022 of the security council
and end the crisis
cease fire to uh save
lives and to abide by restraint
say the lies and to solve problems by
peaceful means while we express our
grave concern
over the deteriorating situation
and our fear that more deterioration
will follow we
appeal to all parties to respect their
commitments by virtue of
humanitarian international law and human
rights law as well as relevant security
currency resolutions that
call for defending the civilian
population and
installations
security council resolution 2472
that was adopted in
2019 to
protect the civilians
we hope this resolution
this humanitarian resolution
will be applied it calls upon all the
parties to look for the
missing persons in a manner
that will help reach out to them
we support all the efforts made by the
secretary general and the specialized
agencies as well as regional
organizations to escalate the situation
and we call for facilitating the
delivery of humanitarian assistance to
the civilians
without any restrictions in accordance
with humanitarian
thank you mr president
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of malawi
mr president
excellencies
may i first of all send condolences
to the families that have lost their
loved ones
in the ukraine crisis
mr president
malawi takes not the resolution tabled
on ukraine crisis
and are co-sponsoring it
we note with great concern
the worsening situation
that has already created grave human
suffering in ukraine
malawi would like to commend
all member states for their contribution
and commitment
towards a negotiated diplomatic solution
to the crisis
as a peace-loving country
malawi reaffirms her commitment to
global peace and security
and condemns any escalation of
hostilities
that strength threaten this common cause
we therefore
take this opportunity to reiterate our
commitment
and support towards a peaceful
resolution of this crisis
more so now when the global community is
focused on fighting the covid19 crisis
and other humanitarian crises
president
the establishment and survive of the
united nations
as we know it today
is largely due to our shared commitment
towards global peace and security
any threats
towards peace and security are equally a
threat to the very foundation of this
organization
and a threat to the progress we have
attained over the years
to make the world peaceful and safer
for humanity and all forms of life on it
the progress that has been realized in
building the global peace and security
architecture
should be jealously guarded by all of us
in the same vein
the sanctity
territorial integrity
and sovereignty of all un member states
must be respected and protected
the territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine is no
exception we are all aware of the
consequences of a global conflict and
its humanitarian social economic and
political catastrophic impacts which are
needless to ever over emphasize
mr president
the world is already grappling with a
number of other existential crises
ranging from the coveted 19 pandemic and
let alone climate change
malawi therefore
commends the restraint shown so far by
various stakeholders in the crisis
and appeals for the de-escalation of the
tension
we call on russia to immediately cease
fire
and withdraw its forces including its
military equipment from ukraine in order
to create conditions necessary for
continued diplomatic engagement
peace negotiations and contact and
dialogue for the good of humanity
the current crisis in ukraine demands a
demonstration of leadership by the un
security council
and all members of the united nations
in a true spirit of multilateralism
let us give
dialogue and peace negotiations a chance
i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of malawi
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
marshall islands
thank you mr president
mr president
mr secretary general
excellencies
i align my statement with that of fiji
and chair of the pacific island forum
states
and i speak also on
my own capacity
as
pr marshall islands to the un
the republic of the marshall islands
welcome this opportunity for the un
general assembly to continue a special
emergency session on the general
sampling resolution 377 a
this resolution known as uniting for
peace was established in 1950 to take
immediate action when there is a lack of
in unanimity among the
security councils five permanent fight
members
on protecting international peace and
security
and never as the united nations general
assembly been
needed more than to correct
the patent self-interest of russia's
speedo
of security council traffic resolution
s slash 2022-155
mr president
the complete military invasion of
ukraine by the russian federation is
without
any rational justification under
international law
and is little more than a ruse
to satisfy
an imperialist agenda
free will
and the rule of law are being overruled
by the barrel of a gun
sadly held by one of us
sadly one of the founding members of
this
u.n family russia
free will
the basics r1b
and the democratic expression of ukraine
is at direct state stake
every democratic country
in the world
should be concerned
because an unlawful invasion
of one of us
is truly mr president
and unlawful invasion
of all of us
and the martial islands will not stay
silent
we will call out this unprovoked and
violent invasion for exactly what it is
tyranny
the u.n charter is very clear
and the g.a is thereafter charged with
expressing accountability for the
immediate situation
if we as the united nations
cannot take action
then as an institution like the long ago
league of nations
we risk our very
relevance
but mere words
or outcry
alone will not change the course of
events
as a small
nation
the republic of the marshall island
condemned
the recent invasion and urges all full
accountability to be established
and we will play our own part in joining
partnership
respond measures to counter russian
aggression
small and large we must all stand in
solidarity to uphold basic human rights
and the rule of law
including those firm
multilateral consequences
our population is small
but our voice can be very loud
as with many other small nations the u.n
is our primary platform
and as with many others in this room
our own history as a people is marked
marred by the last global conflict
for marshall island it has taught us a
valuable lesson
lesson to achieve and preserve
democratic independence and to ensure
our voice is heard directly
dear colleague as it was repeated by so
many other speakers that is important to
speak out
we must all speak out when we see says
flagrant wrongs
in the world
because if we do fail
now
who then
will speak up for us
or our neighbors in future threats
in china fragile region as ours
also facing geopolitical competition
we are closely concerned over the
adequacy of multilateral response
towards ukraine
so while
this invasion poses a challenge
we are also optimistic that many nations
have spoken out and that many more will
do so
mr president
excellencies
a veto
is and will not
will not stop global consensus
and ukraine you have a friend in the
marshall islands
you are not alone
remain strong
thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of marshall islands
i now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of israel
mr president
israel is a country that has experienced
many wars
and therefore knows firsthand that war
is not the way to resolve conflicts
war shows destruction
chaos and tragedy
not a brighter future
the russian attack on ukraine is a
serious violation of the international
order
we have condemned it and we call upon
russia to heed the calls of the
international community to stop the
attack and respect the territorial
integrity and sovereignty of ukraine
israel has long-standing and positive
relations with both russia and ukraine
given our deep ties with both sides
we're willing to contribute to the
diplomatic efforts if so requested and
have been trying to do so in the last
couple of weeks
israel expresses its concern for the
safety of the people of ukraine
including the numerous israeli citizens
living there and the sizeable jewish
communities in the affected areas
we are gravely concerned by the growing
humanitarian crisis
in that regard israel is providing
hundred tons of humanitarian assistance
to the people of ukraine
including medical supplies water
purification systems emergency water
supply kits and winter gear
we are calling up on the parties to
facilitate humanitarian access
mr president
let me conclude by echoing the call of
the secretary general to turn to the
path of dialogue and peace and to
resolve this crisis through peaceful
means in accordance with the principles
of the un charter
i will end with the words of the prophet
isaiah which express in this context and
beyond my government's prayers and i
would hope the praise of all those
sitting in this hole
nation shall not lift up sword against
nation
neither shall they learn war anymore
i thank you mr president
i thank the distinguished representative
of israel
we have heard the last speaker in the
debate on this item for this meeting we
shall hear the remaining speakers this
afternoon in this hall at 3 00 pm
the meeting is adjourned